[Musique]
les shadoks ont pompé les détritus des
jbe et veulent s'en servir comme
combustible pour leur refuser les
shadows qui étaient venus nombreux
assister aux premiers essais de leur
fusée l'évasion shadoks notes avaient
revêtu leur combinaison sera si ces
malheureuses bêtes n'avait pas de
connaissance spéciale en astronautique
d'ailleurs elle n'avait pas tellement de
connaissances spéciales on peut même
dire qu'elle n'avait pas de connaissance
du tout ce que c'est la fusée retombées
et se cassait
si bien qu'à la fin ils essayèrent de
faire partir leurs fusées à la main mais
il ne se passera rien non plus il ne se
passera rien comme ça pendant un certain
temps et même davantage
[Musique]